the lap in a Thai restaurant lies
directly on the beach in the resort town
of B Bona in southern Tuscany owner
Luciana society is known for his
exquisite seafood the fish is caught
locally sea is deeper and saltier here
there are islands warmed thermal waters
and rivers flowing into it our fish is
well nourished so it tastes better and
has more color than fish caught he'll
swim Vaziri took over the restaurant
from his parents in 1995 before that he
was a fisherman which was when he
learned to cook
thank you and all for show of authority
when I was still a fisherman we took the
fish that didn't sell at the harbor and
cook them with pasture every day it was
a new challenge or denied or not brother
Luciano zhaveri was awarded a Michelin
star in 2006 some of his guests even
consider him to be Italy's best seafood
chef he uses simple ingredients that
complement the specific flavor of the
freshly caught fish
a fish soup called cacciucco a la llevo
neza is a classic dish society has his
own personal recipe every morning he
drives to the nearby Harbor when his
cousin Mikayla's boat returns with the
fresh catch
traditionally cacciucco was a dish made
from leftovers of the day's catch
lucha knows as Eddie is a bit more
particular these are the typical kakuka
fish little flavorful bone fishes for
the suitcase for the garnish we use high
quality fish like red scorpion fish back
in the kitchen says Eddie prepares the
ingredients for his cacciucco
shambo's ella ella baz it their Bishop
Assad these are the fish for the stock
here tomato paste and fresh tomatoes for
the garnish they come on top celery
onions and a carrot too so take oil salt
pepper and white wine
fry the fish for the stock with the
vegetables in olive oil deglaze with
white wine and leave to simmer for about
an hour retain the flavor and color of
the fish afterwards it's all put through
a strainer that gives you the stalk the
zesty base of cacciucco next fillet the
fish for the garnish and cook them
together with fresh tomatoes tomato
paste and herbs delicate seafood like
shrimp and lobster are added last
one thing after another this is the law
pour the soup over toasted white bread
top it with the fish garnish and serve
I took a leave on sm4 that's our own
version of kokuto very light in French
because it's cooked quickly it goes well
with the light fresh wine like Rosa from
Tuscany Luciano society has prepared his
signature soup in Hamburg Shanghai and
New York the fish doesn't have to be
from Tuscany importante it's important
to use the right fish not big ones but
small fish with a strong flavor from
reef areas from the sea floor garlic the
Trump bishop more to support even a
portion of kakuka costs 30 euros many
guests travel a considerable distance to
dine here Lapine Etta's 50 seat capacity
is often fully booked well in advance